إنها طفرة كان العلماء
قلقين بشأنها لأسابيع حتى الآن
تشير دراسة إلى أن فيروس كورونا الجديد قد
تحور بطريقة تجعله أكثر من أربعة إلى
خمسة أضعاف تلك الطفرات ، مما
يجعله أكثر استقرارًا ويسهل إصابة
الباحثين في الخلايا البشرية في أبحاث سكريبس.
قال معهد في فلوريدا إن
الطفرة تؤثر على بروتين السنبلة ، وهو بروتين
هيكلي على السطح الخارجي للفيروس
يستخدمه للوصول إلى الخلايا ، ويقولون إن
هناك حاجة إلى مزيد من الأبحاث لإظهار ما إذا
كان التغيير قد غيّر مسار
الوباء ولكن باحثًا واحدًا على الأقل لم
يشارك  يقول الباحثون في الدراسة إنه من المحتمل أن يكون قد تسبب
، وقد تفسر التغييرات سبب
تسبب الفيروس في العديد من الإصابات
في الولايات المتحدة وأمريكا اللاتينية ،
ويقول الباحثون إنه لا يزال من غير المعروف
ما إذا كانت هذه الطفرة الصغيرة تؤثر على
شدة الأعراض وتصيب الأشخاص
أو تزيد من معدل الوفيات.  ويقولون إن
هناك حاجة إلى مزيد من البحث لتأكيد
النتائج التي توصلوا إليها ، يخضع العمل الآن
لمراجعة الأقران للدقيقة الصحية اليوم أنا
ماندي جيثر